hello everybody and welcome to another
MPI for pi programming tutorial video
for parallel programming high
performance computing and supercomputing
in this video what we're gonna be
discussing is broadcast so the idea of
broadcast is so you just have to enter
at one time and the object variable
whatever is broadcast to all of the
nodes so here's a quick example of how
that works as usual from MPI for pi
we're gonna important P I comm equals
MPI comm I've gotta calm underscore
world we're gonna be using rank as well
so rank equals conned out rank now
pretty simple if rank equals zero so
this is the master node we're gonna say
data equals I'm gonna use the alphabet
here we're gonna say a and that
corresponds to the first letter B
corresponds to the second letter and C
corresponds to the third letter so
that's our data it's just a dictionary
of ABC and what number they reckon
alright they rank in the alphabet now
what we're gonna say so if we're the
masternode we specify hey this is the
data else data equals none for now so if
you wanted to have some of the nodes
maybe change their mind on what data is
you could but for now we're gonna say
data equals none on all of the other
nodes and then what we're gonna say is
data equals comm dot B cast so be cast
for broadcast and it's gonna be data
root equals 0 so where are we getting
this from it's going to be 0 and now
what we want to say is print rank
and then just sit at the rank and then
we're just gonna after rank will spit
out that data so let's go ahead and save
that and I'm gonna move it over to the
PI's now and head over here and SC t 8
and number of process is five in the
last video it only spit out two things
just because we only specified things
for two things um but just now like if
these for us we have five so if you
don't have five there your results might
look different than mine but anyways hit
enter SCT eight let's see what we get
sure enough we get the output ranked
zero four one three two and they all
have the exact same data here thank you
to rod cast so you don't have to type it
in like over and over and over and over
again it just adds one more layer of
dynamics plus broadcast is really useful
for things like probably the most
real-world example that most people have
heard of would be something like Bitcoin
where the you know current stat or
status of the entire network is
broadcast if if a node solves a block
let's say it's gonna broadcast it to all
of the other nodes and all of that so
you can do a lot of neat things with
broadcast but obviously this was just a
pretty basic example of what you can do
with broadcast so anyways hopefully you
guys enjoyed if you have any questions
or comments feel free to leave them
below as always thanks for watching